does it
work all
right I have
everyone testing testing
I have everyone's
attemp folks we have a birthday request
so I would like your attention
please uh hi everyone my name is Jeremy
uh today it's my dear friend Jake alam's
birthday so I'd be I think it'd be
really great if we all sang to him today
so on the countdown of three let's all
start all right 3 2
1 thank you
everybody so you old enough to drink now
now is that or you're one year beyond
that you're old enough to drink now or
legally okay
uh okay before we start
today I don't think you need the
reminder but I'm going to give you theer
reminder anyway which is your quiz is on
Monday 3:30 to 4:00 don't be late okay
if you are taking your quiz through the
Moses Center you need to let them know
you're taking the exam that it's not
just to be enough to be registered so
I've been getting calls from them saying
there are people registered they haven't
told me what so you you got to complete
that process CU you
know and it will cover everything
through
what page 160 cash flows basically all
through cash flow no growth so you can
kind relax on growth but growth will
catch up with you on the second question
so last session we were talking about
analyst estimates of growth right now
what did we decide nice to know
but not very useful for a lot of
different reasons one is and I've listed
some of them it's an earnings per share
and much of your valuation you're
talking about growth in revenues growth
in operating income it's a growth in
earnings per share second it's highly
correlated across analyst there's not
much information because they're all
hurting together you don't get that
Divergence of opinion the law of large
numbers working in your favor because
they all track each
other third it's not a great estimate of
future growth they're trying to estimate
next quarters earnings not the next 5
years not next next 10 years
and finally if you use an analyis
estimate of growth in what sense is it
your valuation you've lost control of
the story right in fact if you value
companies or the analyst estimates of
growth you know that in in Excel you can
take the growth rate and tie it to yaho
finance number so everything in your
spread she can actually be already
sourced you're not need it
now so analyst estimates of growth are
nice to know but they really are not
going to drive the value of a company
and the reason I'm saying this is some
of you will come up with a growth for
your company that's very different from
what analyst has to it's good to ask why
what might I be missing but don't get
too freaked out about that you're doing
a different you're you're forecasting a
different metric you're telling a
different
story second we started talking about
sustainable growth and don't let the
equations drive you when you talk about
sustainable growth you're asking two
questions how much does the company
reinvest what is it putting back into
the business and how well does it
reinvest let's take a very very simple
example to illustrate this concept let's
say have a company which has a billion
dollars of capital invested in existing
plant equipment assets on which it's
making a 7 and a
half% return on
Capital which means their operating
income is going to be about 75 million
this company plans to reinvest nothing
in new assets but it's going to maintain
its existing
assets if that is the case case what
will the company's growth look like in
the future if you just maintain your
existing
assets at what but so basically maintain
the existing assets you're going to earn
a billion the invested capital is going
to stay at a billion in fact talk to me
about the
mechanics you know if you have assets
what usually happens to them on a year
toe basis what do accountants do they
depreciate them right to maintain them
what do I have to do I have to have
enough capex so it's not that capex goes
to zero but they have capex said exactly
offet depreciation your invested Capital
stays the same your return on Capital
stays at 7.2% so this year your income
is 75 million next year it's going to be
75 million the year after it's going to
be 75 million in a year in a in a in a
environment where there's no
reinvestment and no change in the return
on Capital you cannot
grow but there can be growth if you can
improve your return Capital it's
efficiency growth right you take the 7
and a half% and make it 9% you're going
to get an increase in income so when you
look at these sustainable growth
equations it forces you to think about
what is the company putting back in the
business and how well is it reinvesting
and those are healthy questions to ask
about any
business so just play it out let's
suppose this company doesn't reinvest
any money but takes its 7 and a half%
return on Capital and makes it 10% next
year what's its growth rate going to be
next year you want to try what's its
growth rate going to be if you go from 7
and a half% of a billion to 10% of a
billion 33% how do you get the
33% so basically you take the 100
million you're going to have income this
year 75 million this year take the $25
million difference you're going to get
33% growth it's efficiency growth but
then you're at 10% you're kind of stuck
efficiency growth this finite you can
grow until you hit that cap so we'll
talk about both aspects of growth today
but you can already see for the long
term you need more Capital coming into
the firm more
reinvestment so let's put this away
let's go back to the slides we were
talking about the growth and return and
equity
and let's build on the concept so we're
talking about growth in earnings per
share right we looked at the retention
ratio which is the percentage of net
income that you put back in the business
and the return Equity it's the oldest
sustainable growth equation around most
people they talk about sustainable
growth that's the equation they're
talking about I'm going to modify that
equation a little bit rather than look
at the percentage of net income put back
into the company which is just a very
raw number doesn't tell you whether
they're actually reinvesting I'm going
to look at that what they actually
reinvest in capex and working capital if
I take the net capex and change in
working capital that's my total
reinvestment and to the extent that I'm
looking at equity alone I'm going to
look at the percentage of that
reinvestment that comes from Equity you
divide that by net income you come up
with what's called an equity
reinvestment rate it's like a retention
ratio but there are two big
differences first difference is in the
cap what's the highest retention ratio
can be we talked about this last session
100% Can an equity reinvestment rate be
greater than
100% so right net cap X can be any
number you can do Acquisitions and if
it's greater than 100% what are you
doing you're raising fresh Equity by
issuing
shares or coming in the with other
source of equity your Equity
reinvestment rate can be greater than
100% which if you're a high growth
company and you're reinvesting a lot
makes sense can it be less than
0% can net capex be
negative capex minus depreciation right
could be negative your change in working
capital could be negative your Equity
reinvestment rate can be negative in
which case your company is
shrinking over time is that a bad thing
it depends on the business you're in
you're a tobacco company your Market is
shrinking maybe this is the right thing
to do the nice thing about Equity
reinvestment rates is they now open the
door through things you could not have
done with the retention ratio really
high growth firms are declining firms
you now have bringing it in through the
equity investment rate for the return
Equity again I'm going to take cash out
of the equation my net income is going
to be net income from non-cash ass which
is net income minus the interest income
from
cash and my denominator of being the
total book value of equity is going to
be the book value of equity minus cash
I'm looking at just the equity invest in
operating assets Equity reinvestment
rate times non-cash return Equity gives
me an expected growth rate in net income
so instead of earnings per share I'm not
looking at net income and now I'm
allowing the company to issue new shares
if it wants to grow at a faster rate a
kind of very mild variant in the first
equation but one that gives you a lot
more flexibility to deal with companies
that don't pay dividends that are
growing fast that are reinvesting large
amounts of
money so I'm going to use an old example
to illustrate how these these equations
work out
2010 you looked at Coca-Cola their net
income was $ 11.8 billion 105 million of
that came from interest income from cash
so the non-cash net income is 11.7
billion their Book value of equity was
25.3 billion you net out the cash the
non-cash book Equity is 18 billion the
return in equity was a mindboggling
64% let's pause right there why does
Coca-Cola such an incredible return
Equity that's a cynical way of saying it
but it's always earned a high return
you're right though BuyBacks could do it
that's not the reason Home Depot that
might be the reason
Coca-Cola could be part of the reason
but it's not the main
reason is it the taste of the soda you
think I don't think so because Mexican
Coke tastes much better than us Coke
anyway right it's not the taste it's is
it the red can you think it's very
aesthetically
pleasing that's not it talked about the
power of a brand name what the power
brand name allow you to do take this
cheap can fill it with water and sugar
and carbonate it and charge you a dollar
a can cost about two cents to make the
whole thing it's an insanely profitable
business a high return business because
that that's what brand names usually
when you earn a high return Equity
everybody wants to do what you do right
the power of a brand name is you can try
in my corporate finance class I wrote a
case for them every semester I write a
new case and this this semester my case
was built around
Celsius now the company that beverage
business is a very difficult business
for a new brand to break into so last
year the reason I noticed Celsius is
four people in this class last year
picked Celsius to Value so what the heck
is
Celsius they said you know you can go so
I went and bought four cans of Celsius
and I tried them all out I didn't feel
any healthier to be quite honest or more
energized and it turns out they were
lying about both those things and
but you can see establishing a brand
name is really difficult to do in this
business once in a while somebody breaks
through really high return
Equity the
reinvestment was 957 million so that's
cap net capex minus depreciation plus
change in working capital but 150
million of that came from debt and as a
percentage of their net income they were
reinvesting very
little you have a really high return
equity a really low reinvestment rate
the product of those two numbers gives
me an expected growth rate of 5.22% why
is it so low because there not much
reinvestment to go it's a saturated
Market not like you can come up with new
beverages that you can keep adding on
it's a high return in equity low
reinvestment company which gives me a
growth rate which is in the single
digits which is what I would expect to
get for a company as big and as mature
as
Coca-Cola let's do a third spin so we've
looked at retention ratio Equity
reinvestment rate now look at look at
the version that would apply if you're
looking at operating income now I'm
going to Define reinvestment rate in
terms of after tax operating income I'm
going to take net capex plus change in
working capital including Acquisitions
R&D Etc divided by the after tax
operating income yes sopia
for example from what I know Starbucks
no if you include cash you'll punish the
company right because when you say
managing the cash well what would
managing the cash will allow you to
do almost but that so you're saying you
don't have much in wasting cash right
that's what you're capturing very few
companies are wasting cash right most of
them roll things over you're right if
you have wasting cash you includeed in
working capital but there's all very few
companies you look at with the big cash
back bance will have that cash sitting
around as wasting cash so even if you
need it for operations if you can find a
way to sweep it into commercial paper
Tes it'll earn a fair rate of return I
will punish companies so I will not
reward companies for doing what they
should always be doing which is find
some good use for cash but I will punish
companies that
don't put their cash into money because
that I will include in working capital
reduce their cash flows and reduce the
value so remember that drug dealer that
I talked about who kept his cash sitting
around he have a lower value because he
keeps his cash sitting around he should
accept venmo or something simpler and
not have a cash balance but that I think
is is is the place to show you punish
companies for badly managing cash but
there's really no reward here because
it's so easy to
do that's a different question yeah
that's yeah that's it's almost like
you're earning a s you're raising
capital from cust customers to invest in
so that's more like debt you got to be
very careful you got to treat it as debt
rather than a cash balance because
you've effectively borrowed money youve
recreated a financing arm within the
company so it's more like debt it go
into your cost of capital maybe it's a
cheaper way to raise debt then to raise
it in the public markets and there I'll
reward you with a lower cost of capital
if you can show me it gives you a lower
cost of
debt so reinvestment rate is in terms of
after tax oper income and here when I
look at what kind of returns you make
the returns have to be stated in terms
of operating income so in the numerator
you're going to get after tax operating
income that same number you start the
free cash to the firm with and in the
denominator you're going to have Book
value of equity plus book value of debt
minus cash it's called invested Capital
it's an accountants measure of how much
capital is invested in the company this
not this term roic or Ro its different
versions has become this almost magical
number that consultants and bankers talk
about it's the way they separate you
from them so do you know what a Roy is
he said no you're not one of us so now
you know what a ro is I don't know
whether you want to be one of them but
aoy is very very simply a a return
measure for the entire company so when
you look at Ro basically you're
capturing the quality of the investment
the growth and operating income is the
product of those two numbers
reinvestment rate times return on
Capital so when you have a company that
earns a high return on Capital there are
two ways you can reward
one is for any given reinvestment rate
you can grow at a faster rate than a
than a pure group company with a lower
return Capital the other is you can
choose to have the same growth rate as
the other company and return more cash
so it becomes a level through which we
can reward or punish companies for being
really good about how they pick
projects so let's let me give you two
contrasting examples of companies so you
can see how these metrics play out in
199 9 Cisco's reinvestment rate was 106%
you might not remember but I computed
Cisco's Acquisitions into in 1999 they
invested like 2.5 billion came up with
this huge net capex huge
reinvestment their reinvestment rate was
107% they reinvested more than their
after tax operating their return on
Capital was
34% this is an extremely unusual thing
to see when you have a really high
reinvestment rate and a really High
return Capital you have a special
company Cisco 99 was a really special
company why because it was able to
maintain both numbers at high levels its
growth rate reflected that in contrast
if you looked at Motorola that year its
return on Capital was 12% its
reinvestment rate is
52% 12% is not a bad number 52% is not a
bad number but not a bad number times a
not a bad number gives you not a bad
growth rate right so when you look at
company growth rates it's not a number
you can play with as somebody valuing
the company you got to think about does
this company have the potential to do it
so 2000 actually valued Cisco for one of
my first one of my books that I wrote
that year and one of the questions you
you had to deal with when EV Valu Cisco
is can they keep doing what they're
doing right that's what they earned in
1999 but they do this in 2000 2001 2002
because now because if you think about
now forecasting up saying what's the big
deal why can't I keep assuming ass uming
that they keep reinvesting 106% and
earning a 34% return on Capital ask you
is it getting more will it get more
difficult or less difficult as you go
forward in time to maintain these
numbers so you and tell me
why one is that economics marginal
Returns the best project come first so
that's that's one let's suppose their
modular return on Capital project is is
flat they can get these
projects second and this is the biggest
problem as you grow you get bigger as
you get bigger it gets more difficult to
keep doing what you did last year that
106% reinvestment rate was nine
Acquisitions in
1999 it'll have to be 11 Acquisitions in
2001 it'll have to be 17 Acquisitions in
now do you see why as companies grow
their growth is going to moderate
there's a reason Google and Facebook
have signal to the world we're not high
growth companies anymore you 160 billion
revenues you can't be delivering 20%
growth so when you look at why growth
comes down it's going to come from all
of the reasons one is the return on
capital of 34% might be overstated
you're not it's know things are going to
catch up with you second the
reinvestment comes from very
Acquisitions what happens if that
acquisition stream starts to dry up it
could be that they're getting bigger and
every one of these started working
against Cisco in the following decade
Cisco was run by John Chambers 1999 he
was viewed like Jensen Wong is now like
yesterday when I was in CNBC I said the
company that Invidia reminds me of most
is Cisco the do during the do com what
does Nvidia do it supplies the chips to
make the AI architecture right which
right now everybody wants to spend tens
of billions on that's exactly where
Cisco was during the dot boom they
supplied the architecture for the
internet incredibly valuable company and
then you get to the following decade and
I'm not saying this is going to happen
to Nvidia the same CEO same company
doing exactly the same thing continuing
to do
Acquisitions during the next decade was
a lost decade for Cisco it's market cap
stayed flat for an entire decade
and that's why when you think about how
companies succeed and say why can't they
keep doing what they're doing it's a
world changes around you the company
gets bigger and eventually what worked
before stopped
working so this this accounting return
equity and return invest Capital becomes
almost the center of the universe and
it's the problem here both the numerate
in the denominator accounting numbers
right numerator is an accounting
earnings number denominator is an
accounting book value number and as I
said everything accountants do or don't
do is going to affect your return
Capital but 15 years
ago I decided because I was so bored to
write a paper that was so boring I fell
asleep multiple times while I was
writing the paper so if any of you have
trouble falling asleep at night you can
download the paper read it I guarantee
you by page two you're going to be
sleeping like a baby it's probably
healthier than taking a you know
melatonin or something and having vivid
dreams about Corporate Finance quizzes
or valuation quiz is it's a basically
it's 65 pages long about all the things
accountants to that I have to reverse
when I kind try to come up with the
return Capital let me give you a few
examples a couple you should be familiar
with one is remember R&D and leases that
we capitalize it to get a better sense
of what are you actually making on
projects if you have write offs anytime
accountants write off something it
creates problems for me why because you
take a mistake off the books your
invested Capital strings and if I'm not
aware of it I think you're taking great
projects when in fact you're taking
terrible projects and you keep writing
them off Goodwill nightmare to deal with
when you do return Capital do you leave
it in the invested capital in which case
you're trying to count for something
that's future growths maybe or do you
take it out so essentially the entire
paper is about adjusting the accounting
numbers to get a better sense of the
accounting return Capital so try
estimating this for your company
mathematically it's going to be easy to
do but then asking yourself do I trust
this number as a measure what they're
actually making the projects entirely
different question right and I leave it
up to you with your company to make that
judgment so we've looked at growth in
earnings per share growth in net income
growth and operating income let's talk
about what happens when your return in
capital or return Equity is changing
over time you saw a little bit of this
on the quiz right on on the first the
start of the class test where my return
on Capital went from 7 and a half% to
10% I got a 33% growth rate in that year
not because I reinvested but because my
existing assets became more efficient
when you have a change in return Equity
or return Capital you add this
additional layer of efficiency so that's
the second term here is in addition to
the return Capital times the
reinvestment rate there's an efficiency
growth number so some of you are valuing
companies with the return on capital is
a really low number right now and that's
going to be disappointing right low
Returns on Capital are not good for a
growth perspective but if that 3% return
on Capital over the next 10 years is
going to become 8 or 9% you could have
some substantial growth in your company
just from improving your return on
Capital so efficiency growth is
something that can add to your growth
rate it's not permanent you can't have
it forever but it's something that can
add to the growth rate during the period
of your
assessment so what what I'm going to do
is I'm going to show you five companies
all of which have the same growth rate
and I want you to think like an investor
and rank these companies from most value
adding
growth to perhaps most value destroying
growth so all five companies have a 10%
growth rate but here's how they got
there company a had a reinvestment rate
of 20% and a return on capital of 50%
Company B had a reinvestment rate of
100% and return on capital of 10%
company C had a reinvestment rate of
200% and a return capital of 5% notice
why the growth is always 10 200 you know
2 * 005 is 10 so each of them is getting
to a 10% growth rate with very different
choices of reinvestment rate and return
of capital the last two also have a
change in the existing return on Capital
and existing project they have
efficiency
growth so my my question is a very
simple one which of these companies is
growth going to be most valuable the
cost of capit for all of these companies
is 10% which of these companies is
growth going to be most valuable and why
yes firm four you think but firm four
will firm five because you have no
reinvestment remember you get growth
only for one year right after the first
year what happens you now hit the you
got the Improvement done you're
reinvesting nothing so you're going to
one year of 10% growth but then your
growth is going to be 0% 0%
0% so what not reinvest now we not get
the so in a sense the reinvestment
growth is you're right it's a freeb
growth you'd rather have it but you
think about the value of growth as long
term if this is all you can do is
improve your efficiency and get a
one-year growth and you get zero growth
after that you're kind of done
right yes
clear they earning 50% return right in
which of the five companies are you
actually going to destroy value as you
grow clear stay stay in there tell me
which of the five they all have 10%
growth but one of the companies are
going to get value
destruction focusing on on the metric
you looked at why do you like company
one 50% return on Capital right cost of
capital is 10% company two just runs on
in place it actually doesn't add or
destroy value because it earns its cost
of capital but take a look at company 3
it's growing but it's taking projects
that make a 5% return on Capital this is
value destroy growth your company will
actually get more valuable as you try to
grow because the amount of reinvestment
you put in for that very little growth
rate will destroy your cash flows now
I've talked off and on about good and
bad businesses about 60% of businesses
on the face of the Earth are bad
businesses my definition of a bad
business is you struggle to earn your
cost of capital Airlines automobiles
Telecom increasingly
Banks and if you're in a bad business is
when you try to grow guess what happens
you become less valuable an airline that
is trying to grow is my vision of an
investing
nightmare airlines that try to grow in a
bad business you're going to be taking
projects you're going to be growing but
you're going to be destroying value as
you grow so I want you to remember that
return on Capital versus cost of capital
it's I know it's kind of a mechanized
equation but you're thinking about can I
earn more than my cost to Capital When I
Grow the answer is no growth becomes
useless so the efficiency growth is
great and I think that's a good point
you want the free growth but beyond that
you need to be able to reinvest and earn
more than your cost of
capital so now I'm going to step back
and talk about the way I want you to
think about your valuation because many
of these look very mechanized Roc it
looks like you just pull up historical
data and do it but I want to step back
and think about what you need to think
about when you think about the growth
for your company and how you get the
cash flow
so here's my most generic way of
thinking about estimating future cash
flows and this is what that Ginsu
spreadsheet is buil around so I'll give
you the background for what I do there
you have a company you want to project
out free cash flows right its margins
can change so what do you do you start
with the Top Line revenues and you
project out Revenue growth in future
years help me out here if you are if you
have a company you want me to value and
it's your company when I ask you what's
your Revenue growth you want to give me
a high number low number what what you
like to do high number right we'll talk
about why we can't just use 80% growth
for every company so we have to start
with Revenue growth that's going to
depend on the size of the market it'll
depend on the competition it'll depend
on what your product is that's your
starting point but growth alone doesn't
get you there right that makes you
revenues you got to convert those
revenues to profits so the second number
we need is a measure of what kind of
profits you can make a profit margin as
oppos of revenues again I'm going to
come back to you if I let you pick you
want a high number of for that or a low
number you want a low margin or high
margin high margin low cost so basically
we haven't even talked about the risk
you're right if you want address so you
want high growth and high margins
right but then I'm going to ask you
third question to get the growth you
need to
reinvest you want a low reinvestment or
a high
reinvestment low reinvestment okay lower
reinvestment because otherwise your cash
flows get lowered you see in a perfect
world if I let you pick you want high
growth High margins low reinvestment
right so now you have your company and
you're saying what do I do with my
company so I'm going to set up the
structure for you to think about what
your company can essentially accomplish
let's start with Revenue growth look at
your company you're trying to say how
much can my company grow the first place
to look at is the market it's going
after if you're a small company in a
really big Market you have more
potential for growth I'm not saying
growth is guaranteed you have more
potential for growth so you're going to
look at the size of the market relative
to your company there's a growth in that
market
matter you want a large Market that's
growing the reason Nvidia is in as good
a shape as it is is it sells AI chips
which is an 80 billion
Market but even better for NVIDIA that
market is growing 30 to 40% year because
so many more people want to invest in AI
chips how big is the market how quickly
is is it
growing already you can see for many of
you that's going to constrain how much
you can grow any of you Val Altria which
is a Philip Morris
tobacco if you're valuing
Altria the total Market is pretty
stagnant Altria is a big chunk of that
market it's not growing you put in a 20%
growth rate I'm going to come back and
say where what are you going to do so
that's the first place a good start
second you want to estimate what market
share you will get as a company and what
are the things that will go into this
first is you'll start with the current
market share if you're Altria you
already have a 40% market share there's
not much room to grow or more
specifically we're talking about the
beverage business right if you're Val
Coca-Cola your Revenue growth is going
to be pretty limited because you're
already the largest beverage maker in
the
world in contrast if you're valuing
Celsius and you can figure out a way can
they have 25% growth yeah if they could
find way to pull it off they could grow
at 25% and not end up with more than
like a 10 or 12% market share Celsius
has higher potential expected
growth than Coca-Cola because it has a
smaller market share that you can build
up it'll also depend on industry
economics what does that mean there are
some businesses where you get splintered
competition the nature of the business
and other businesses where you get more
winner take all
businesses now I think the biggest
change for me of the 21st century is
what companies have done to many
businesses to make them win a take all
businesses let's take the advertising
business 25 years ago the advertising
business was an incredibly splined
business the largest single player in
the world might have been the New York
Times which had like a 2% market share
why so low because it was splinted by
geography by language I mean you had
newspapers but now know newspapers were
kind of restricted you know who the
largest advertising companies in the
world are right now who dominates that
business it's Google and Facebook or
alphabet and meta if you prefer the
newer names you saying what allows those
companies to have 35 or 40% market share
because they're online they do a
platform Nothing Stops them from going
geographically across regions they've
taken a business that us be splinted and
made it a business we have winner take
off let's go back 20 years car service
business
largest car service company in the world
might have been a taxi cab company in
New York City maybe that guy on
Seinfeld owned 150 cabs probably a 5%
market share today the largest car
service companies are Uber and lift and
DD and grab because right sharing is
allowed what used to be a splintered
business to be a Consolidated business
I'll make a confession when I first
valued Uber my biggest mistake was
missing
what Uber did both in terms of being
able to get a market share and in terms
of what it did to the total market so my
very first valuation of uber in 2014 and
I'll show you that original valuation
because I got pushed back from Bill
Gurley who was a benchmark Capital VC
one of the first uh investors in Uber
and he said you're missing what Uber can
do to the market he's absolutely right
because what I did not factor in is how
much bigger Uber made the car service
Market people who never took car service
before took car service now and how much
two or three or four companies could end
up at 25 30 35% market shares so as you
look at Unity the industry economics
you're looking at what's changing and
finally you want to look at what your
company does relative to the competition
right you're competing against others
why would people pick your product over
the other so ultimately your endgame
when you think about Revenue growth is
you think about Hey What Can I Do how
big is the market what's my market share
what will it end up becoming so as an
example I'm going to use the valuation I
did of Airbnb at the time of its IPO do
you remember when ABNB went public it's
actually a very odd time to go public
November of 2020 you know why that was
an odd time right we're in the midst of
covid everything had shut down and airb
andc now is the best time to do it and
actually they timed it right because
their competitive Advantage was its
absolute maximum nobody wanted to T
touch a hotel company but they were
willing to think about Airbnb so my job
is to come up with the revenue growth
rate for Airbnb and I you know when when
a company goes public it files what's
called a prospectus a prospectus
includes all the things you see in an
annual report plus additional
information on what they plan to do with
the proceeds and how much they plan to
raise so in the prospectus Airbnb
claimed that their total addressable
market now it's called D because become
something that VCS are very fond of of
of throwing around was about 3.4
trillion and the serviceable addressable
Market was about 1.8 trillion trillion
not billion trillion and I had to stop
and read those numbers again because
here's why collectively all of the
hotels in the world put
together at revenues of 700 billion in
2019 2020 of course you can't even look
at because it was terrible 2019
collectively all so what's Airbnb
already saying in their
prospectus that they will take the hotel
business and triple or quadruple its
size implicitly what is the what is the
you know how does it happen how does a
market which is 7 so what would Airbnb
do that allows the whole Market to
become three times as much
yeah but that's just but then you also
need more people to travel right
collectively we all have to spend more
money on traveling the implicit thing
was we'd now go and know five times as
many trips than we used to because of
airbnb's existence we can push back on
that but you can see the underlying
story there is we can make the market
much
bigger Uber in San Francisco tripled the
size of the car service market in San
Francisco and the way it triple the size
is at some point in time people said I'm
not buying a car anymore there's an Uber
or a lift within 2 minutes of me anyway
so people moving to San Francisco not
buying cars and living off car service
that's the expansion of the market so
we'll take it at it so that's their
estimate I I thought they were
overreaching but basically the way I
checked the numbers I added up the
revenues for the hotel business but this
was my starting point in valueing Uber
was in val Airbnb was getting a sense of
how big is the hospitality
business if any of you Val Young compan
compies there's no way around doing this
You' got to make your best judgment and
you know what numbers are going to be
all over the place you're saying Google
will have an answer it'll have 15
different
answers and you'll have to figure out
which one you trust more but that's your
starting
point what the heck is this I don't even
know what it is but every single
Prospect is that came out of Silicon
Valley at what's called a flywheel what
a flywheel basically says is as my
company gets
bigger it's easier to get even bigger
it's called a networking
benefit it's easier to see with the
right sharing business then with this as
Uber gets bigger what happens drivers
want to be on Uber because it's the
biggest car service company customers
want Uber because it's the app with the
most cars so each time you get bigger it
actually increases your chance of
getting bigger the flywheel basically is
a a fancy way of saying my market share
when I'm done is not going to be 4% of
5% it's going to be 35% 40% 45% you can
already see we're laying the foundations
for an Airbnb valuation big Market this
flywheel is pushing towards we'll have a
big market share and if you bring those
numbers together you're going to get a
revenue growth rate that's going to look
mindboggling from a hotel business
standpoint but it reflects the economics
of Airbnb as a company so that's your
first stop start with the revenues so
we'll go through the Airbnb valuation
fully when we get later on but I wanted
to start thinking about that for your
company What's the total Market what's
my market share what can I
do second stop what kind of margins can
you when I first threw this out I want a
high margin but it depends on the
business you're in the first driver of
your margins is what's called Unit
economics what is unit economics measure
it measures what you make on the next
unit that you
sell say two contrasting companies right
let's take Microsoft
say get on the Microsoft website you
subscribe to Office
365 why you need you need Windows you
need you need PowerPoint you need word
how much does it cost now like
$79.95 a year so Microsoft collects your
money right up front in your credit card
right how much does it cost them to make
that extra copy of Office 365 for
you nothing right there's no gnome
running around Seattle saying oh my god
I've got to create copy for so and so
they bought this it cost them nothing
all of it is pure profit the unit
economics for a software
company are outlandishly good because it
costs almost nothing in contrast let's
say you're a Manufacturing Company an
extraordinarily efficient Manufacturing
Company you're an automobile
company what do your unit economics look
like first to sell a car what's the
first thing you need to do you need to
make the damn thing
right and if you're lucky you might be
able to make it for 60% of what you plan
to sell it a good Manufacturing Company
you might end up keeping 40 cents out of
the dollar you see already where this is
going right the the number that will
capture this is the gross profit margin
you're going to see for your company
that measures if you look at software
companies that gross profit margin might
be 80% 85% 90% for even the most
efficient manufacturer in company that
gross profit margin if you're lucky will
be 40% 45% if you start with a gross
margin of 40% you're going to be lucky
to end up with double digit operating
margin because there's all this other
cost below if you're valuing a
manufacturing company and I'm putting
this out as an advanced notice for you
and I see an 80% operating margin on
your company in near 10 I'm going to
have some questions about what exactly
you're manufacturing and who's making
them and how you get that markup and
maybe you can give me a really good
explanation you know what invidious
gross margins
are it's about
80% isn't it a manufacturing
company so how so tell me why how can
you earn 80%
margins okay so Taiwan semiconductors
makes them and then they mark them up
obviously immensely who do they sell
them to mostly big tech companies right
me so this is a very strange game so
Taiwan semiconductor makes the chip for
$10 or
$50 Invidia marks it up to $2,000 and
sells it to meta and Microsoft for
$2,000 you see why this system is going
to have some friction in it right some
push back first if you're taian
semiconductor what's your reaction going
to be to what's happening here why am I
not getting more of this right you I am
the guy making the chips you can design
it as much as you
want so first question is how come tsmc
is willing to accept this and the other
is if you're meta or Microsoft paying
$2,000 for a chip that you know cost
only $150 to make what's happening
internally at those companies what are
they talking about they want to make
their own
chips this process is well in play it
hasn't happened yet because right now if
you want to build an AI data center you
are kind of stuck buying Invidia chips
Invidia bargaining power is at its
absolute
maximum but it's only going to get
smaller over time doesn't mean they'll
become a low margin company but there is
no way you can maintain an 80% margin
when you're selling to the four biggest
tech companies or half your revenues and
it's coming from a manufacturer who
without whom you can't make these ships
in the first
place so if you're telling an invidious
story in my Invidia story I started with
that 80% margin I did push it down to
60% still in an astonishingly high
margin but I think that the pressure
from both sides will push so you look at
Unity
economics have you heard of um Kathy
Wood what does Kathy Wood
do she AR she basically an investment
manager she's she's a big Trend caller
right she thinks oh and she's been
pretty good about calling trends at
least until about three three or four
years ago so she got into doccom she got
into
Tesla and then she has a team of people
very smart people who have no idea what
they're doing when it comes to
valuation they churn out these
valuations you look at them and say have
you ever been in a
business so they value Tesla this is
about five years ago and they give Tesla
70%
margins my reaction is you have to make
the cars you know that right cost money
to make a car car but it's almost like
they treat T like a software company
that you could drive a piece of software
around town and call it a car you can
try that if you want but it never worked
for
me when you look at the margins in a
valuation think about the unity
economics in the business if the margins
are 40 50 55% like the F for software
companies it must be that your unit
economics are like Microsoft but if you
have a Manufacturing Company those
margins even for a really good company
are going to be 50 16 18 the highest
margins in the automobile business are
Ferrari why because it makes only 8,000
cars and then what does it do mark them
up
immensely we'll talk about Ferrari later
in the class but it is a company with
immensely strong margins because of its
pricing power so unit economics are
first stop second is economies of scale
we know what economies of scale usually
translate to as you get as you get
larger your margins go up but what what
is the you know what is it that drives
that decline in margins over time so if
you every company that I ever talk to
claims to have economies of scale half
of them are lying how do you determine
whether a company actually has something
behind its economy
scale okay so I it's true you can look
at operating leverage but you're looking
at one year if they truly have economies
of scale and I look at the last 10 years
what should I see I should see Revenue
growth of 12% maybe then when I look at
sgna or one of those fixed costs I
should see growth less than
12% it's economies of scale those
numbers should be growing at five six 7
per. in other words what causes
economies of scale is not magic you just
don't automatically get higher margins
as you get bigger it's that your costs
have to grow at a smaller rate than
revenues one of my biggest concerns as I
was Ring Uber as an investor from
2013 through 19 is its revenues grew 30
40 50% a year but it costs grew 30 40
50% a year as well I had the same
problem with Netflix immensely
successful company in terms of growth
adding
subscribers but for the bulk of
Netflix's existence as its revenues went
up it costs actually went up even
faster what's the biggest cost that
Netflix has the
company it's a Content cost right and
what's the Netflix model you turn on
Netflix someone it's 20 shows every day
right that's how they got their model
going I mean I've described Netflix the
story for Netflix as being a hamster on
a wheel and the analogy is to grow their
subscriber base they have to keep making
new content and it's getting worse
because their new subscribers are in
India and Spain so they might make
Spanish content you got to make Hindi
content basically the content machine is
in overdrive you make make 20 shows two
step so as they grow their content cost
grows more than proportionately it's
only in the last two or three years that
Netflix seems to have woken up to this
problem that finally Reed Hastings has
said this is not a viable business model
we need to find a way to bring content
cost down the first signal that they
were doing this is they stopped
reporting subscriber numbers that sales
pitch they've used for as long as
they've been around is look how many new
subscribers 2 years ago they said they
were not going to kind of emphasize that
which kind of also tells you they're
looking at how do we bring content cost
down so economies scale so Unity
economics economies of scale
competition let's say have great Unity
economics you have great economies of
scale your costs are coming down but
everybody around you has exactly the
same right you're all all your costs are
coming out you're saying good we all get
more profitable unfortunately in a
comparative market that doesn't happen
right CU what happens one of the players
breaks away and decides to cut
prices so when you he I mean I hear talk
about how AI is going to reduce the cost
for grocery stores and make them more
profitable and my reaction is if
everybody has it nobody has it so if
every grocery store uses AI to manage
inventory better and sell stuff better
the end game is they're not all going to
be they're actually going to get less
profitable because the prices are going
to come down customers will benefit but
there's really no payoff to profit so
competition matters so those will drive
your target margin as to how you get
there the first is where are you right
now if you're a money losing company
you're at minus 75% margins it's going
to take you a while because you got to
get deep you you're so far underground
that you got to dig your way up second
it's going to depend on what managers
emphasize more in the business are they
more focused on scaling up the business
are they more focused on delivering
profits and that's why I said for net
for Netflix this happened two years ago
in reing finally said we've got to stop
focusing on getting more subscribers
start to make money in Uber the turning
point is in 2019 when darak kski finally
said look we can have more Riders more
drivers But ultimately we've got to
figure out a way to make money which
effectively then translates decisions
that translate into profitability in
finally some business models turn the
corner quicker than others so depending
on the business model you pick I might
give you you know get you to the Target
margin in year three rather than year
seven but at the often at the expense of
lower
growth so that's the second stop you got
revenue growth I want you to think about
the margins so think about your company
think about I want you to start thinking
about Unity economics and economies of
scale I'll give you a way in which you
can take past financials and try to look
for Clues on both of them but that's
your second
stop in the case of Airbnb here's how I
built up to their to to their revenues I
started with gross bookings gross
bookings are what you pay on Airbnb for
a property but remember Airbnb doesn't
own the properties they're just
intermediaries right any of you own an
Airbnb property no we know what
percentage of your of an Airbnb fee that
you pay goes to Airbnb that that total
price it's about
14% so when you pay $250 for an
apartment in San Francisco 14% goes to
Airbnb so their slice is their revenue
so that's the slice of revenues could
that 14% increase could be but you're
already kind of capping out right 14% is
a big chunk to take for just connecting
people to other people so in this case
that that that's my Revenue the revenue
growth over time decreases because as
your grow picking you know bookings get
to 155 billion you're already six times
bigger than Marriott in terms of people
going through you you're you're the
largest hospitality company in the world
if you do that so it's a big story of
you know you're succeeding your your
bookings are going up and the margin
over time if you know if you notice
starts at a negative number there were
money losing at the time they were in
public and over time I'm pushing those
margins towards 25% me give you the bad
news first there is no Hotel company in
the world that makes 25%
margins but luckily for Airbnb they're
not a hotel company they're a booking
company and there are two publicly
traded companies that make their money
through travel bookings one is Expedia
and the other is
booking.com xedia is this mixed model
where they actually buy entire sets of
hotel rooms from hotels and they and
they then they make the difference so
there's an inventory CA it's a more
expensive model booking is a pure
intermediary and in in in 2019
booking.com had margins of about
35% their margins dropped off obviously
in 2020 everybody's margins dropped off
so when I pick the 25% margin those were
the two companies I focused on to get my
target margin I'm not suggesting all any
of this is going to be easy right
because you are making judgment calls
you are going to have you know if you
don't like the word subjective get used
to it it is subjective in the sense you
have to make your best judgment given
the data that you have but you're trying
to get a sense of what will happen to
revenues what will happen to margins and
as a final piece let's talk about that
reinvestment piece again let's look at
the
drivers of how much you'll have to
reinvest first you know the metric I use
to measure the the efficiency of
reinvestment is the ratio of revenues to
invested capital how many dollars of
revenues do you get per dollar of
invested Capital if you're efficient
you'll get a lot more dollars if you
have to work for that that revenues be
lower number so I'll give you a
contrast intermediary companies often
have three four5 doll of revenues per
dollar of capital
investor infrastructure companies have
less than a dollar in Revenue per dollar
of capital investor because it's a very
Capital intensive business so some of
this you might say I'd like a high sales
to Capital ratio but if you in a
business that's capital intensive that's
really tough to
do now once you get that sales to
Capital and as you start to forecast
out factors to consider as you get
bigger is it getting easier to reinvest
or more difficult in some companies your
sales and capital ratio might go up as
you get bigger in some other in other
businesses it might go down depending on
the competition second if you're a
business with a lot of excess capacity
you might be able to deliver a really
high sales to Capital ratio because you
don't have to invest this morning in my
MBA evaluation class know one of the
students has pick Boeing to Value
anybody in this class valuing
Boeing Boeing last year had fewer planes
sold than any time in the last decade
one of the worst years in the decade why
what's what's what are the what are the
problems at
boing let's not get overboard I mean
there are all the boing planes crashing
otherwise they'd be but the they first
had that Boeing 737 Max Fiasco this was
about 6 s years ago where they had
problem they didn't fix it that the
Dreamliner had issues each time one of
these things happens it piles up right
he's saying I mean Boeing was considered
one of the great engineering companies
in the
world was is the key word so one of it
is that credibility
yeah the strikes which is every you have
unions and basically whenever they
strike they have to s shut their
assembly plans down and the problem with
it is once you shut those plans down
they're so big to open them up often
takes 6 to 8 weeks that's revenues laws
so you got labor problems you got
credibility problems what
else and who who the customers for both
boing and first you know who's their
competition there's only one other
company in the world they compete with
which is airbud right this is the
duopoly that's a good news why is it a
duopoly because it's such a rotten
business nobody else wants to get into
the business that's the bottom line it's
a very Capital intensive business so the
only good news for boing is they're
probably not going away right it's one
of two companies and they're going to
and they're selling to Airlines which
are among the most Basket Case of all
businesses to sell to how many healthy
airlines are there in the world if you
take out the gulf
Airlines and you know which are
subsidized they can buy aircraft the
only growth area for aircraft is in Asia
and the Middle East it's a slow growth
business two players and Airbus has got
a larger market share because of the the
737 Max and recent proms but Airbus is
not a well-managed company either there
but for the grace of God goes Airbus as
well so two years from now who knows
what the crisis will bring but this
person is you know believes that Boeing
can come back that they can go back to
the number of craft they were selling in
2019 let's say that happens put a
revenue growth to capture that do you
need to reinvestment to get there no
they have a lot of excess capacity you
can get there with very little
reinvestment you might have to retool
the plants and get them up to board so
this is a case where you're going to get
growth with little reinvestment at least
until you get to a cap where you run out
of excess capacity so that's a factor to
look at is does your company have a lot
of excess capacity and can it use it to
grow and third take no no disk it's
having its moment in the sun right why
because there is two drugs out there we
GOI and OIC that are delivering insane
amounts of growth and
profits this is what I call accidental
success right because were they meant to
be weight loss
drugs no notic was this small Danish
company that made drugs for diabetes
that was the core area they were tiny
relative the big farmer
companies turned out that two of the
drugs they develop for diabetes we go
and OIC ended up having this very good
side effect which is you lost weight and
it's a testimonial to what we value as
Humanity that having a weight loss drug
is worth about 50 times more than having
a diabetes drug let that you know kind
of rattle around your mind that's
neither your problem nor my problem but
that's the reality but you know when no
no disk invested Capital to get OIC and
W GOI in
2011 there's a lag in the farmer
business between when you reinvest and
when you get growth so when you value
these companies what you're getting is
the effect of reinvestment eight years
ago N9 years ago and you can live so
today you value Nova no dis you might be
able to give them high growth because
for the next five years they need to do
nothing they can continue to live off
those drugs but eventually if you want
to grow you got to go back into that
business so that lag can affect the
final amount reinvested so Revenue
growth margin sales to Capital so when
you look at that those are the three
drivers that drive value everything else
feeds into them and you can already see
everything about businesses feeds into
those
numbers so with Airbnb there's my
revenues my operating margin improves
over time as my margin goes from
negative to positive my losses become
profits so you can see the Abit and the
after tax Abit for the sales to Capital
ratio I used the sales to Capital ratio
of two roughly what they' been able to
maintain over the lifetime the way to
read that is you take the change in
revenues in any year and divide by two
you're going to get the reinvestment
that year it's as simple as that so
every year take the change in sales
divide by two you get the reinvestment
in that year and subract the
reinvestment for the after tax operate
income is my free cash flow focus on
that column right this is my upbeat
story for Airbnb right what's my free
cash flow negative negative negative
netive negative negative negative am I
surprised no because I'm ambitious about
the company if I'm ambitious they got to
reinvest the negative cash flows reflect
eventually the cash flows turned
positive and I also track based on my
estimates what kind of return on Capital
the company can end up making because
remember my growth and margins give me
my operating income my reinvestment
gives me my invested Capital it's called
an imputed return on Capital I'm
estimating what kind of return on
Capital the company can make can make
with my
forecast so I know it's a lot of
different pieces in there but I want you
to start thinking about I know the
quizzes is right now you're not even
thinking about your company valuation
but when you come back you have about a
month before you turn in your DCF for
feedback it's not for a grade so if you
haven't picked a company I won't even
ask you you know when you're going to do
it you know if you want the feedback it
better be before March 29th which is
when the value valuation is Du because I
don't think you can value a company
without picking it that' be an amazing
valuation so get started on this process
because it's a process let it rattle
around it's not something you can sit
with a spreadsheet and go bang it's not
mechanical you have to think about the
company the business the competition
before you make that final judgment
right now one thing about sales to
Capital ratio and this is something you
can say about all those numbers is the
way we compute sales to capit is you
take the revenue in any year the company
has and divide by the total invested cap
of the company that's called an
aggregate sales invested Capital but you
can also compute a marginal sales to
invested Capital what is it you take the
change in revenue from year to year and
the change in invested capit from year
to year what are you trying to capture
you're trying to capture whether this
number is changing over time so
aggregated numbers are nice but
sometimes it's good to track that change
to see as you scale up whether your your
reinvestment needs are getting larger or
smaller smaller because that's going to
affect your value as a
company so let's review where we are
discount rates cost of equity cost of
capital reflect the risk of the business
cash flows free cash Equity free cash FL
we talked about growth historical growth
analyst
estimates or fundamental growth the
sustainable growth last piece of the
puzzle the biggest number in your
valuation is your terminal value right
let's talk a little bit about why we
need it in the first place and how to
estimate why we need it is very simple
we're just getting tired of estimating
cash flows year one year two year three
year four and you say can I stop now can
I stop now said finally you can
stop and when you stop you can't just
ignore what happens after that the way
you put closure is by estimating a
terminal value so I'm going to talk
about three ways of estimating terminal
value one of which I think should never
be used but gets used all the time
especially at
Banks and many of you will end up at
Banks using this approach and if you do
please don't show your valuations to me
just hide them away and the two others
you can use and we'll talk about in what
context you computed cash flows for the
next year next two your three your four
your five you get to your 10 you want to
computer terminal value here's the first
way you can do it you can do a
liquidation value what's a liquidation
value you stop in your
10 you liquidate the company you sell
off assets
I use this sometimes with small private
businesses whether it's a single owner
and you say look it's unrealistic to
assume the business can go on so that's
liquidation value so if you're a
business built around a keyers you're a
plumber and you're 65 years old you said
value my business and I ask you when
will you retire and you say at 75 I'm
going to estimate the cash flows the
next 10 years the end of the 10th year
I'm going to sell off your Vans and your
Client List and get whatever I can like
quation value the second is the most
common approach you see in most value
it's called it's assuming that beyond
your 10 your cash flows continue
forever you continue to Forever at a
constant growth rate you have a growing
perpetuity that's the equation you see
in almost all textbooks the cash flow in
your level know you always have to go
one extra year divide by R minus C
that's a growing
concern but you don't have to people
assume that that's the only way to do it
you can actually argue that maybe when
you get to your old 10 your company
won't continue forever might continue
just another 15 years you can use an
equation called a growing annuity
equation it's a little messier than a
growing perpetuity but effectively it
means your company will have a finite
life after your death you Val
Zoom great platform great technology but
I don't think it's going to be forever
might be a 25 year life or a 30-year
life you get to your 10 rather than and
assume things continue for every much
it's an extra 15 years and then the
technology dies it's growing in it and
finally and this is the one approach
that I find should never be used is you
get to your Tad and rather than try to
estimate cash flows what you do is you
apply a multiple multiple of e in your
attend multiple of revenues multiple of
earnings this is the banking template
for terminal value it's a horrifically
bad
practice but it's a practice
nevertheless you would see in m&a in
banking
valuations what's wrong with it why
what's wrong with using a multiple in
your tent to get a terminal
value remember we talked about intrinsic
value versus pricing I say pricing was a
bad thing but it's different right in
pricing what's the question you're
asking how much would I pay for a
company given what other people are
paying for similar companies in
intrinsic value the question asking how
much should I pay for a company given
its cash flows when you make your
biggest number in a discount cash flow
valuation into a pricing it's no longer
an intrinsic valuation it becomes a
forward pricing everything rides on that
eight times
ABA so when Bankers use it I think they
need to be honest about this is not an
intrinsic valuation it's not a DCF it's
a forward pricing with a front end of
cash flows because you think somehow
this makes it more sophisticated so if
you're staying with intrinsic valuation
your real choices are between
liquidation value
and this cash flow continuing concern
value either Perpetual or finite so
let's take that Perpetual growth model
right it's a model that you'll see in
every textbook it's often taught as the
only model to get terminal value what's
in the numerator cash flow in year 11
what's in the denominator R minus G
right it assumes that cash flows grow
forever it's one of the most misused
equations in finance because it comes
with limits that people often violate
here's the first one since this is a
grow grow rate
forever it cannot be greater than the
growth rate of the economy in which you
operate why is that why can't a company
grow at a rate faster than the economy
it'll become the economy then what
globalization okay keep going it be the
global economy then what right you're
going to hit cap sooner or later so
first can it be lower than the growth
rate of the economy yeah some companies
will shrink over time can it be
zero can it be
negative what kinds of businesses would
you put a negative growth rate in
perpetuity you the example of tobacco
right you're Val
alria what Universe are you going to put
in a 3% positive growth rate forever
when smokers are getting older you're
your I would argue that company like
cocoi you might actually argue that
their best days are behind them because
their markets the customer base is aging
and as it ages after the next 10 years
you you know how often I see discounted
cash flow valuation with the negative
growth rate perpetuity I don't think
I've ever seen
one which tells you something about
human nature you feel almost unnatural I
can't put in a negative growth rate yes
you
can if you're valuing a fossil fuel
company right now they're looking okay
right let's say you go to the 10 your 20
and if you truly believe that there's
going to be enough of push back against
fossil fuels you might say Exon Mobile
great cash flows for the next 10 years
but after that I'm going to put in a
minus 3% growth rate forever because
fossil fuels become a smaller percentage
of the energy so leave open that
possibility that your cash flows can be
that the growth rate can be negative
yeah you could but effectively does the
same thing right what what does having a
negative growth rate do think about your
numbers they'll peak in your 10 and then
they shrink and effectively they're
disappearing so you don't even have to
put a finite life it happens on its own
right so you could put a liquidation
value but this effectively does exactly
the same thing you make aus3 into -5 -7
- 10 you make it minus 100 it's
liquidation right there right so it
gives you that freedom to decide how you
want to scale your company
down and finally that consistency thing
we talked about at the start of this
class K into play as well so when people
say well when I estimate growth rate in
perpetuity should it be in nominal or
real terms you see the difference real
versus nominal what's the answer to
that ask them how they did the cash
flows if the cash flows are in ninal
terms the growth rate in your terminal
value has to be ninal if they were in
dollar terms the growth rate has to be
in dollars if they're in peso terms the
growth rate has to be in pesos the same
consist argument Ki
in so I'm going to give you what I use
as my proxy for the growth rate forever
I got a huge amount of push back on this
so I'm going to give you my rationale
for why I still stick with it so you're
in
2035 in your in your Excel spreadsheet
and what I'm asking you what will the
growth rate in the US economy or the
global economy be in dollar terms after
2035 be honest with me what's your
reaction when I ask you that question
what's the nominal growth rate going to
be in 20 your reaction is who the heck
knows right you say as a macroeconomist
don't waste your time they have no idea
either you know how much time analysts
spend trying to estimate the unestimated
because that this is basically what it
is you'll have entire meetings
three-hour meetings what will the growth
rate be after
2035 so I'm going to give you the proxy
I find most useful as an estimate of the
growth rate we you know to start your
cost of equity and capital you started
with the risk free rate and we talked
about what goes into risk free rate
there's a expected inflation component
and an expected real interest rate
component a risk-free rate is expected
inflation plus an expected real interest
rate what goes in the ninal growth rate
of an economy there's expected inflation
plus an expected real growth rate in the
economy in the long term and that's all
we care about in perpetuity the expected
real interest rate in an economy has to
converge on the expected real growth
rate of the economy let's talk about why
I don't know about you but now was Tau
about real interest rate my professor
used apples not dollars because when you
talk about real interest rate it's about
goods and service you borrow 100 apples
you got to return 102 that's a 2% real
interest
rate so if real interest rates require
that you return what you borrowed with
extra goods and services if the economy
is not growing at that rate you can't go
around promising people a 3% real
interest rate the economy is growing
only
2% the real growth and the real interest
rate in the long term will start to
converge which actually if you think
about it also means that when a economy
has negative interest rates it's really
bad news right because what is it
telling you that in the longterm the
nominal growth rate of this economy will
actually be negative
Japanese interest rates have either been
close to zero or negative for much of
the last 30
years so why are people so down on the
Japanese economy including many in
Japan what's happening in Japan that's
going to it's an aging population you
can't fight demographics right and
what's terrifying is you have a country
that is seven times the size of Japan
that is facing a demographic Cliff as
well if Japan goes into negative growth
the rest of the world can live with it
it's it's still in terms of the global
economy if China has a similar problem
and there is this real possibility of a
demographic time bomb in China it'll
drag the entire global economy down with
it so that's a catastrophic scenario but
when you talk about negative real
interest rates and they arrive so the
ter time is when the
Chinese interest rates turn negative
that's when we all should be panicking
and looking for that spaceship that Elon
is building for us to get to Mars right
maybe there's High inflation there so
when you look at the risk free rate
you're getting at least a sense of what
investors think about ninal
growth so there's actually some good
news in the T bond rate being 4 and a
half% instead of 2% right is what it was
3 years ago which is part of it is
higher inflation and part of it was this
expectation that real growth it's
actually dropped in the first six weeks
of the year which suggest that people
are bringing down their expectations of
real growth a risk-free rate is not just
an interest rate out there it's kind of
an investor measure what they think the
future delivers in terms of expected
inflation expected real growth so that's
one rational I use the risk free rate as
my proxy for the ninal growth rate
because the real interest rates and real
growth rates tend to convert Lisa you
look a little puzzled so what's what's
what's bothering you
yeah so don't go to the second part yet
so basically do the first part first so
is everybody come so the interest rate
part expected inflation expected real
interest rate ninal growth is expected
inflation expected real growth if real
growth and real interest rates converge
the risk-free rate is
aoxy and of course the push back you get
is That's So theoretical is that really
true so what I did was I went all the
way back to
1954 and I looked at the t-bond rate in
each period and the real growth and the
inflation each period because if my
argument is right when inflation is low
and real growth is low t-bond rate
should be low and the best predictor I
found of nominal growth in the US
economy and I compared it to
macroeconomic forecast the best
forecaster of macroeconomic growth in
nominal terms in the US economy has been
the T bond
rate every year since 1954 you run a
contest t-bond versus 50 top
Economist the t-bond wins every single
time are you surprised by
that I'm not and here's why when an
economist gets on CNBC and says oh real
growth this year is 4% how much money is
riding behind what he just
said absolutely nothing I can get up and
say oh 40% real growth nothing there
when a when you buy a t- bond you buy a
$100 million worth of t- bonds and you
said rate that's real money moneyback
forecast will beat non- moneyback
forecast every single day so when we
start class after the quiz I want to
complete the terminal value calculation
I want know so make sure you come stay
around after the qu if you finish early
go get a cup of coffee come back because
we'll continue a terminal value
discussion y so the going concern finite
valuation when you say you're going to
estimate the future cash flows at the
terminal value you're just extending the
DCF calculation further out doing a
without doing the the explicit P so what
you use you use a growing annuity
formula so let's say you get to your 10
you say you know what I 15 years of
growth left at 3% a year right you could
do your 11 year 12 year 13 go all the
way to your 25 or you can use this
growing innity formula it looks very
much like a growing perpetuity and you
can get a terminal value with 15 years
of cash flow going at 3% it'll just do
all at once by the way you were right
about video I saw you on CNBC it's
exactly what happened they be earnings
but they're trading flash like little
down in a sense markets have their minds
on their own right so let's see how it
plays
that question about pricing at Terminal
value um I I think I just don't really
understand why it's a problem
to assume price to be a say let's say
use eight times to get the terminal
value right
where did they get
the uh probably same story as the
normalized B no they looked at public TR
compan in the business and look at what
they trade at so what they're doing is
they're taking a pure group they're
looking at what investors are paying in
that pure group so have it done they're
applying to your companies have it done
everything they're doing is okay if
you're doing a pricing because that's
what pricing is find a pure group you
see what people are paying the problem
is when you put that number in your
terminal value in there in a discount
and you call an intrinsic valuation
you're kind of undercutting the whole
idea of intrinsic value intrinsic value
is about what you pay for a business
based on cash flows so if I'm an AI
company and other people are paying 20
times earnings and I put that into the
terminal value I get a really high
intrinsic value but it's not because the
cash flows are high but because there
are people out there willing to pay 20 T
revenues for this kind of compan so by
making the biggest number in my inic
valuation into a price essentially I've
made sure it's not an intrinsic
valuation anymore it's a forward price
but then
like Biggest Part relation is also like
cash flows revenues they also one cash
flow that the terminal value is the
dominant cash flow right if it's a
pricing it's going to drown out all of
the other assumptions you made for the
first but then how does how is assuming
how's working for pricing for I know
assets or company name Seer whatever
much conceptually worse
than the fact that we apply pricing you
know you don't apply pricing at all
right you apply just cash flows and
growth Pap you never bring in what other
people are willing to pay in an
intrinsic valuation well we do bring in
what people are willing to pay just in
the market for the firm's
produce in what way you know like I when
I'm Val in Coca-Cola I will assume that
people are willing to pay $1 but that's
different we're not talking about I
think I don't understand how that's what
customers to pay for your product that's
actually a price out there so that's not
a market priceing then terminal value is
what the buyer is willing to pay for my
that's perfectly fine if you're pricing
the company okay but Bing the company
means you're about running a business
and saying what are my cash flow is
going to be so there's nothing wrong
with pricing something just don't call
it a valuation valuation says I'm buying
a business got cash flows what's the
value of what I'm getting in return of
the cash flows it's got to stay cash
flow Focus you cannot bring in eight
times Abid five times earnings three
times Book value make that your terminal
value and call it an
intrin than hey how are you very good
thank you um I wanted to ask about um
lease expenses and what adjustments you
make on for unlubed free cash flow I
read part of your paper on it I
understand why you adjust your operating
income and add the lease the interest of
police but how do you adjust um your
capex and it's got to be the Delta the
Pres see remember one way to compute
capex is take the change from one year's
balance sheet to another right so we
have present value relases show up as
debt in year one we got present value
relases in debt too the change the
present value becomes your net
capex yeah I read intuitively think
about this is the way it works let's say
you're a retail phone you have 10 stores
you leased in your watch you now
increased that to 12 stores how will
that show up the present value release
commitments will be much higher now than
they were a year ago taking the
difference will then capture your
effectively what your reinvestment
should be for that de whereas you have a
mature retail firm that's not opening
any stores the present value lease
commitments will be high but they will
stay pretty stable over time they might
even flatten up which what if they
flatten out if there's no change don't
add that's good because then how are you
growing you're growing by improving
margin increasing revenu so you
basically are growing by through the
revenue growth margin your reinvestment
number will stay low which is what it
should be if you're not opening new
stores right and do you would you adjust
depreciation at all or will
automatically adjust itself right
because it's tied to the present value
lease commitment so if your lease
commitments flatten out your
depreciation will also flatten out right
so you in the depreciation aspect you do
include the depreciation element of the
lease right that's why it's net cap if
stay with the present value lease
commitment change from year to year it's
net of depreciation right basically so
you don't even have to bring
depreciation in you take that change in
present value and that becomes
effectively the net capex on your leas
hous so okay so the I think I get it so
the the depreciation if we don't do net
cap analogy right there's two ways to
get net capex one is to do capex minus
depreciation the other is to take the
net fixed assets yeah in year one and
take the net fixed Assets in year two in
balance sheet and that difference is
also net capex right okay so yeah yeah
so I'm doing the same principle here so
if I know the leaste debt last year and
the leaste debt this year the change in
that least debt is like a net cap X in
Le you would okay but you would take the
change in the would you take the right
of asset or the CH it's either way right
because because the counter asset so you
can take the lease asset if you want
take the change in the lease asset and
call it reinvestment but you're doing
the same thing you'd have done if you
take net fixed asset if it decreases
going to be like
depreciation and you technically add it
back and the the lease liability part
you leave out completely because it's
like a that isue you do but since
they're both the same don't do both
sides pick one side and take the change
from year to year should be the same as
doing the other side but if you if you
went to lever then you would do it
differently anyways Le it shouldn't
matter right leases are a financing
expense and you're doing Le cash flow
should exactly so all that'll be
difference of deducting it as one
expense you deduct it as two
expenses depreciation plus interest
expenses some of those two will be equal
to the least expense your net income
should be
unchecked thank you hello Lis I have a
couple question yeah um you said that
private companies should be valued as
liquidation value so should not have to
be but if you have a you know if you
have an owner who can't pass the
business on because it's a personal
service business that person needs to be
around to run the business so doctor for
instance okay you can't say well you
know you get to be 75 let your son
become the doctor because he doesn't
have a medical degree how the heck is he
going to become a doctor right so it's
so if it's not a personal service
business you can still do what we do
with public companies okay the question
is will the person buying the business
from you discount it because you might
have brought in clients so this is the
thing we talked about at the keyers and
then you're saying like you have to you
could sell off your Client List you
could right if you want if it's a
liquidation value right if it's
liquidation value you break it up into
pieces and you sell off each piece for
whatever somebody would pay for it right
um but could I Val value what the client
listed you could at that point in time
and some and'll depend on what people
think your client was will bring them in
terms of you know new contracts so it's
very difficult thing to do unless you
know exactly
what Competitive Edge that Client List
will give somebody okay um and then
additionally my other question is could
youe
explain
they let's let's take the real growth
rate is less than the let's take the two
scenarios right the real growth rate can
be less than the real interest rate or
higher right let's say it's less let's
say the real growth rate is 2% and I'm
going around promising people that I can
deliver 3% okay the
right because if I don't if 2% is the
overall real growth in the economy and I
promise people
3% something has to give where am I
going to get the extra 1% in terms of
goods and services if I'm not growing at
that rate so with my real growth rate is
less than the real interest rate there's
going to be this difference that you're
not covering and either you're going to
have to default because you don't have
the growth which will bring real growth
down so basically you're trying to
deliver something something that cannot
be delivered if the real growth rate is
less than the real interest
rate real growth rate requires more
products and services out there and if
you're not growing at that rate you
can't deliver that real interest rate
that you promise people
okay real interest rate is not doll the
terms think in terms of goods and
services right 100 apples you got to
deliver 103 but let's say your orchard
grow grows only 2% a year you're only
102 apples okay why the heck are you
going to come up with the third apple
right so the real interest rate will
have to come down to match the real
growth rate because with that okay your
real growth rate is much
higher and so let's say you're growing
at 5% here and you're promising people
only 2% then other people will enter the
borrowing market and try to push up the
rate because they have the capacity with
the apples to pay off more so either way
there will be pressure over time for the
two numbers to converge doesn't have to
be next year doesn't have to be two
years from now eventually the two
numbers you'll have to convert okay and
I shouldn't even be concerned about like
phot addressable market and market share
and all that stuff and like um not a
company your when you have a small
business the market is so huge that you
can put in 30% growth in your company
and you're still going to be a tiny
piece of the market right so total
addressable markets become more of an
issue when you're building a business
could potentially be a huge business
we're trying to convince people that
it's going to be much bigger than any
company out there right now because
you're going after much bigger market
and then can I ask you one last question
what do you think about any of these
companies like if you've heard of them
as CLS um
ACN um
CTS are these all Consulting companies
Tech they're all like offshore Tech
consultant they're probably all small
they're probably not high-profile
companies M have you heard of infosis
yeah they out sourcing company uhhuh do
you think that would be a good one to
like yeah that be a pretty decent one to
have an ADR so can get the be okay what
about like TAA Consulting T Consulting
Tata they're very they're Tata
consulting and infos is are probably the
biggest Outsourcing companies in the
world oh so that wouldn't
really I don't know whether that's what
you're looking for they're not software
Consulting companies they're more
Outsourcing companies with the software
component okay but that doesn't mean you
can't use them for the beta calculation
might not work for the pricing part
right but I can use it for the beta even
though it's really big I don't have to
counter big and small that shouldn't
matter for the beta ba beta just
reflects how you know what drives your
overall business well wouldn't it have
more risk compar to the market because
it's a smaller
company okay um and then with ypr wh Pro
that's You' got three big Indian
Outsourcing companies there right T
Consulting servic info Pro about so when
you go on United and
you know you have a problem probably
ending up with an infosis or to
consulting services or wha that that's
what Outsourcing is this is what US
companies that have outsourced their
their it their just offshore recruiting
it's it's everything to do with this so
it's out it's not they're all
Outsourcing companies okay and then to
find stuff out about them like I should
just do you don't need much did the PE
group of
betas yeah like well I was just thinking
about those betas I just or or those
companies as come you can find them on
capit like you there's a little tear
sheet where they'll tell you what the
companies do okay be enough okay thank
you you're
welcome first question I was gonna ask
was the same one to explain the argument
so I just listened to it um um then the
second thing I was wondering was I did I
tried I tried the weekly challenge three
um it didn't I did not get the one with
spin it with the R&D which part did you
have struggle with because the first two
were pretty mechanical right the leases
convert circularity part that's where
things when the interest coverage ratio
yeah that's because I used that and then
from there kind of everything was messed
up because the problem with leases when
you try to compute an interest coverage
ratio is because interest leases
interest expense you overstate the
rating when you start right and then you
have the imputed interest expense so
basically once you capiz leases you get
an interest expense that now go goes in
which could change your rating that's a
circular right that's why if you look at
my rating spreadsheet it comes with the
check off box in Excel for the
iterations was the okay because I didn't
get that part that's what that's how you
get it it's like doing through it
manually is a pain in the neck because
circularity manually means you do it
then you redo it then you redo it until
you converge it might take you 20 tries
to converge you put into Excel and you
set it ask you to compute the interest
expense based on the leas Deb what it
except does that's that's the one you
attached in the solutions exactly
because I I tried to do it by hand and I
didn't I didn't even think that's a
factor that's what circularity will mean
when you do it manually it means you you
you repeat the process over and over
until you Converge on something pretty
close to the right answer um so that so
my numbers were all off but for the most
part I felt like probably the value of
it was just practicing capitalizing
leases and R but it's also illustrative
of the fact that whenever you have I
mean circularity is emic in many parts
of finance and you know it's a feature
not a but right because do you need us
do you want us for our cost of debt for
our companies to fix that circularity
it's already done the FCF Ginsu
spreadsheet the circularity the
iteration is checked off so it'll
automatically do it for you if you use a
rating spreadsheet it's already built I
was going
to okay you have a rating for your yeah
I have a rating it's Triple B you're
rating there's nothing there's no you
already that's that's what I was UN sure
synthetic rating need in the first place
um and then sort of um to that end when
I was